[Musique]
c'est en 2015 que les new gravity ont
été repérés sur le parvis du théâtre de
champ fleuri
ce groupe de jeunes qui pratiquent le
parcours a tapé dans l'oeil du directeur
des théâtres qui leur a donné leur
chance
voilà en fait à force de s'entraîner là
tous les jours ben lui passé quand il
rentrait chez lui ou quand ils venaient
quand ils retrouvent pour travailler
tout ben du coup nous voyez nous
entraîner tous et il se disait demandé
si on était structure ou pas bien nous
nous on lui a dit oui on avait une
association voilà qui gravite y est et
du coup il a dit que ben voilà bunge
être quand vous proposer tout benouza
proposait justement de créer enfin de
faire un petit show démonstration de ce
que nous on peut faire dans le cadre du
toto total danse depuis deux ans les new
gravity ont donné plus d'une soixantaine
de représentations dans le cadre du
festival total
récemment ils ont eu la chance de
s'envoler pour l'île maurice et mayotte
pour beaucoup ce voyage était leur
premier un rêve atteint pour le groupe
et ça a été toujours le rêve le rêve du
groupe d' objectifs du groupe sur tous
ces deux voilà c'est de voyager ensemble
de faire des trucs ensemble et voir plus
loin vraiment et là le fait vraiment que
ça que le voient là le théâtre et et les
organisateurs de hip hop event du hip
hop évolution nous inviter à aller
là-bas ben ça m'a fait ça ça m'a fait
beaucoup ça m'a fait acheter ému quoi
parce que pour moi je pensais pas qu'un
jour ça allait se faire outre les
spectacles les new gravity ont aussi pu
visiter découvrir de nouvelles cultures
momo d'origine mahoraise a présenté sa
famille à ses amis
des souvenirs inoubliables toute la
famille qui est venue regarder parce que
voilà quoi c'est l'enfant du pays si à
la famille qui vient pas voir c'est un
peu bizarre mais en dehors des
spectacles oui on a une seule une
semaine à mayotte on a pu profiter on
est parti voir la famille de momo à quoi
c'est ça quand tu vois sa famille à quoi
on est parti à la plage on est allé
faire la sortie bateau où je me suis
noyée
on est allé faire plein de choses et
c'était bien à mayotte ce qui m'a marqué
moi personnellement c'était les les
enfants là-bas enfin les ados 10 ans
comment comment il bossait il avait rien
mais dès qu'on leur donne un petit truc
il était heureux ils étaient contents un
petit tapis pour faire du break alors
que c'est sur du béton il était pieds
nus ou en savourer tout et franchement
ça ça motive ça motive à aller plus loin
pour christine veinards qui a permis à
ces jeunes de réaliser leur rêve et qui
les a suivis tout au long de leur voyage
cette tournée n'est que le début de
grands projets certains c'était leur
premier voyage donc de les voir avec
leurs grands yeux émerveillés de tous
c'était vraiment quelque chose de très
émouvant tout cas pour moi ça leur a
donné en tout cas envie de continuer de
travailler encore plus et d'aller de
rêver à la france enfin la métropole à
londres états unis enfin voilà tout d'un
coup ça a été pour eux un électrochoc
aussi et à mayotte a été assez
extraordinaire puisque nous avons été
dans la famille de momo ci et là c'était
quelque chose de jeudi on en pleurerait
quoi en fait tellement c'était c'était
super fort et de voir aussi comment ils
ont évolué mais vraiment et moment de
savoir d'où il venait ça lui a permis de
de repartir sans dire bon voila je viens
de là et voilà ce que je fais
aujourd'hui
les new gravity soit désormais pouvoir
vivre de leur passion mais aussi être
formé pour devenir plus tard éducateur
sportif
[Musique]